народний на захід сонця сайт у створні
активістами для перевірок
достовірності декларації даси служба
active
на і склад ніші по ріверу це за кордон
нейстат до декларанта у
адже видно і електронного реєстру
115 українців можна латиф
задекларував і 375 офшорних компаній
у 40 днів вкрай почет
у деклараціях про тему жадібна загадки
про те чим а йти фірми майну икаем на
владний зростання курсу і цапу садів ти че
всі декларант та зареєстрували всієї
своєю
і на мені компанії подальшу земного
щастя навіть сильний ми сумніваюся для
щоб вірить і що записано на ті
компанії потрібно провести 375
розслідування крім
там глухий кут а ти там та ж самий тип порно
у мальту в сінгапурі та по 2000 ті
компанії володі чим поширюється компанії
вимкнена за що вереск ринку такі
перевірки мало б срубає і національне
агентство забутої залякування корупції
а влітку для тіла на батчаті відставши ж
в законі проза втечі ні крути читку не
прописано, що декларант і мати в ніс
цього реєстру далекий промоїну своїх
фірм стакаємо тулу машинам закону
непогоду тел вру травневий коліт
декорації pid контроль він лише підсумку тут
поважає що загину маніпуляції з мій
будинок може вказувати і на порушення
закону про залякування kurupt & sam вже
виробництва дутова ще всі мої, але ж
їх волосся в тому числі і найвдаліших
особах ми не допомогти йому більше тофу ми
не зможемо притягнуто їх давид паві
дальності затягни ван і похвалитися мої
але заїр вдалим особливо ми просто suite
як ти хто ж подавати декларації так
і ти їх батька блузку мільйона і типу давай
додому декларації з паршею sich in touch
з вами дальності так їм шину може він
і батіг edge і мало високо по саду тіл
прикладом український журналіст і у своєму
розслідуванні
ви івановичу давно насадок крадені
росіян немає і вілли на іспанському зборищі
заступника секретаря та redbul та лотків
ського нардепа ігоря кононенка
заступника міністра енергетики та у ряді
днк то на вигляд президента Петра Порошенка
закривати щоку рубці обіцяють
на зрозуміло то пашуть захід і
правоохоронцям менших crying я все ще
будуть виявлені за значення у деклараціях
по садових також нею в їх рудін вілли
або так і яхти лазні з кірів вул.
активісти
результати ми c бажаним абу здаємо його я
про відкрити а кримінальних інший